so John you've got to spend time here
absolutely yeah now is it correct do we
need to apologize
we're not that welcoming to you know
most people are so welcoming customs
even not so much no I went up to when
she was shooting I was shooting
something in Montreal so I flew back to
see the kids and and my wife and customs
everything was fine and and then one
week just got unlucky and there was a
guy about my age seemed a bit grumpy and
he said you see he said yeah he said you
an actor and I said yeah he goes what do
I know you from and I said I don't know
if you'd know I mean we did the American
version of your British office strike
one
I love that show the UK burst I get it I
get it
and then he said who you visiting wife
and he said she an actress and I said
yeah said what I know her I said I don't
know and he said what's her name and I
said Emily Blunt as he was writing
something anyway you
like stamped my passport with fear John
also I did encourage him that he would
be welcome more if he stopped wearing a
baseball cap because I just said you
look so American that makes it better
prejudice as well he went out and bought
himself a tweed flat cap no we look good
we know like something out of a Guy
Ritchie film you look great
and he walked down the street and it was
like the Sun came out cuz suddenly a guy
turned him anyway you lose the baseball
hat just like sweet that's what it says
and was it nice because you'll be having
your children spending time here quite
nice because are they American children
you said it kind of sneering me put your
cap on you'll be fine dry heaves you
were like our America
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean semi American they do become
quite well my oldest daughter became
quite British sounding of the course of
the year that I was here for Mary
Poppins and she was sort of saying
things like bath and water and now she's
back to water
[Music]
you